hello everyone and thank you for all of
your birthday wishes it was it was a
very nice of you I really enjoyed all of
them but now it's time to return to our
to our series a 2013 World Chess
Championship match between Vishwanathan
Anand and Magnus Carlsen this is game
six of their match and before we check
it out
we do have one photo challenge before
this game and this one is gonna be a
little bit different so prepare
yourselves here it is how many of the
players here do you recognise so unless
you know all of them and unless you're
willing to write all 36 of them then
just write the number how many of them
do you know but if that's the case if
you do know every player from this out
of the 36 players here then do share in
the comments section and you know have
everyone marvel at your vast knowledge
and it would be very interesting you
know if we divided the players into
teams of six you know if every row was a
team which which row would be the
strongest team also nice thing to
consider so let's get let's get back to
the game it's game number six and you
remember in game number five first four
games were drawn game number five had a
very promising position then that whole
Bishop to c7 business a lot Causton to
you know take the game into into a
pretty drawn end game would would it may
be a slight advantage for him but Indian
Carson managed to push that all the way
to win here we have a game where Anand
now has the white pieces and he has a
chance to retaliate and it's very
interesting when on the island also lost
his round one game against Veselin
Topalov in 2010 when he was defending
his title but then he immediately
bounced back and also when he was
defending his title against Boris
Gelfand gets under one a very nice game
in Game seven and then again Anand
managed to recover it so now he has the
white pieces will he be able to
retaliate against Magnus Carlsen
so Anand opens with E 4 we have e5
Knight to f3 and Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 so the rule Lopez is on the board
we have Knight to f6 s just a second
nice to have six the Berlin defense so
like in game for cousin once again goes
for the Berlin defense but in in game
four on and one for the main line he
canceled and here he avoids the main
line he goes for d3 okay Bishop to c5 we
have c3 both players castle rook to e8
and rook to e1 a6 Bishop back to a 4 B 5
Bishop to b3 and now d6 and here we have
Bishop to g5 and since this Bishop is in
c5 it's no longer able to go back to e7
a lot of a lot of people were very
excited when they saw Bishop to g5 and
since you guys really enjoyed the tweets
in my previous video here I also
prepared a tweet by onigiri onigiri says
about this move exciting start 10 Bishop
g5 created an annoying pin and now h5 h6
g5 looks scary if you weren't prepared
and the Magnus Carlsen probably isn't so
very nice tweet by Gary now let's see
how how Carlson deals with Bishop to g5
Bishop to e6 and here aren't continues
Knight B to d2 later they said that
Bishop captures F captures and a 4 a 4
would have been better for white simply
allowing islands to control the tone of
the battle but okay Anand has a
different idea
he plays after Bishop to e6 he goes
Knight bTW - we have h6 Bishop to h4 and
now cousin captures on b3 we have a
capture some b3 and ok this doubles the
beep on but doubling the beep on isn't
all that important on gets a nice semi
open file for the rook and also this pin
is now again very very very very
annoying and unless Carson okosan is
willing to push g5
it will be very hard to get rid of it so
first cousin goes nice to be ate the
rare system that that cousin says that
he enjoys playing quite a lot in those
days and here on earth plays h3 again
they criticized this move after the game
they said that maybe d4 would would be a
bit nicer forcing matters after Bishop
here but captures on f6 Queen captures
on f6 and now d5 closing the position c5
and then C 4 and before it would would
have been better for white and
maybe the weakness of the a sex pawn
could have been exploited better but you
know and the other doesn't agree with
this he wants to keep the pin to this
night alive and he proceeds with h3
Knight B to d7 we have nice to H 2 and
now Queen to e7 since I'm no longer has
a has a light square Bishop Carson wants
to get his Queen over to e6 we have
Knight d2 f1 Bishop to b6 and knights to
e3 and now Queen does come to e6
you know eyeing on that b3 pawn b4 as
it's better to push it forward than 2
then to defend it and now a 5 by pushing
before on a cross and is now able to
push a 5 and now Carson gets rid pretty
much of his only weakness
B captors and a5 Bishop captures an a5
and now Knight h2g for Bishop back to b6
offering a trade of rooks and eyeing
that night on e3 we have Bishop captures
Knight captures Knight captures Queen
captures and here again it's a pretty
pretty drawn position and here Queen to
e2 would be the ideal move for Anand
simply connecting rooks then rook would
be able to capture and also the Queen
would be guarding the night on e3 but
here Anand went for Queen to g4 and
again a lot of players were very
surprised by this move such such a one
such player as Hikaru Nakamura who
tweeted a slightly confused by game 6
once again Anna makes some strange
decisions when he has the opportunity to
complicate this is Nakamura actually
talking about the Queen g4 move as he
also was expecting Queen to e2 so cross
and immediately takes advantage of this
he he plays Bishop captures on d3 we
have F captures and e3 and now Queen
back to e7
we have looked to f1 now c5 the only
move that pretty much allows Carlsen to
push for any advantage as now now it's
actually on earth who has doubled pawns
and it's once again Carson who has only
one point chain on and has to punch in
and once again cousin has a slightly
better endgame for no special special
reason he didn't really do anything to
achieve it it's just that Anand decided
to play queen g4 instead of Queen e2
so we have to King to h2 and now c4 we
have d4 rook to a-1 capturing rook rook
to a1 recapturing and now Queen to b7
I'm eyeing on that
efore pawn and the Queen is pretty much
stuck there defending it and here we
have rook to d1 it's a it's a move that
really makes life difficult for Anand if
he played d5 closing the position then
this point is no longer weak if black
ever wants to push for anything he will
have to expand then white will be able
to recapture maybe maybe push this pawn
to e4 would be a much easier position to
play for Ireland
instead I don't place rook to d1 and
here we have Queen to c6 capturing
immediately would have been better
because now Carson gives on yet again
and the opportunity to put d5 and here
d5 Queen b6 attacking the e3 pawn what
even Allah wants to go for rook to e1
giving up this pawn temporarily and then
after rook to a5 attacking the pawn
Queen b6 now you get Queen here and now
if Queen captures then Queen captures
would be white would be able to at least
draw the game and if you try to defend
this with rook to b8 then you can you
can even go Queen a7 or even a rook to
a7 and then with threats against the f7
pawn white white would hold this to a
draw but after Queen to c6 on plays
Queen to f5 and now Carson definitely
does capture on the on d4 we have pawn
captures and now rook captures on d4 you
can't capture with the point 1 double
because you're a pawn is now hanging so
rook has to capture and now Anand has
three pawn islands rook to e5 attacking
the Queen Queen f3
the queen is pretty much stuck now
defending d4 pawn as well as the rook
and although black doesn't have all that
much here at the material is equal on
the board but it's black that can
eventually that can play this position
forever and simply wait for white to
make a bad decision so Queen to c7
we have King back to h1 Queen to e7 now
piling up money for bond from the other
side
Queen to g4 we have king h7 now
back to f/4 g6 and kink 2h to kink the
g7 simply first improving the position
of the King Queen to f3 and now rook to
e7 and here and on the didn't like the
idea of course and pushing h5 and H for
then go rook to f6 and Queen to e5
this will really improve blacks position
a lot so he decided to release the you
know the tension from the board
he played Queen to g3 but this is
basically a pawn sacrifice it's a it's a
pawn sacrificed from this point that was
doubled so a nun thought that this would
be fine so rook captures we have Queen
captures rook captures on e3 Queen
captures rook captures and now rope to
d5 attacking the b5 pawn and here we
have rook to b7 defending the pawn so
it's not much but it's a rock ending and
cousin is a pawn up should you know so
you should be able to hold this to a
draw rope to d6 we have f6 and now comes
h5 King to f7 King to f7 was a move that
Carlson thought after the game you will
also be able to check out the interview
with the players after the game
h5 would have been better probably
because now cousin played f7 and I done
found this very nice pawn sacrifice with
h5 and now Carlson has to capture it and
after G captures an H 5 it's a you know
his pawn structure on the King side is
not terrible you know this is so much
better than this and this one point will
actually be able to control all three of
course and pawns so rope to d5 attacking
d h5 pawn king g6 defending and now King
to g3 we have Cook to b6 now comes Rock
to c5 and f5 team to h4 we have a rock
to e6 now Carlsen in order you can't
really make any progress here you can't
move the pawn rook captures here you
can't go in with the King and this is
the position
Anand had in mind when he sacrificed the
h5 point and this is definitely a nice
idea and here Carlsen really doesn't
have a way to continue playing this you
can't really push simply rook captures
so in order to continue pushing this
position for something more than a draw
Crossan has to sacrifice some material
as well he plays rook to e6
now we have rocky after some b5 and now
rook the e4 with Czech forcing iron
islands King back king h3 now comes King
to g5 and here rook to b8 rook to b8 is
not the greatest of moves here if you
play b3 immediately
story that's before if you play b3
immediately
b3 immediately then you get a rook to e3
check King moves and now rook captures
on c3 and now as for pawn captures
captures you do you are down two points
but again it's a position that that
should be drawn for white but you don't
even have to go into this instead of the
immediate b3 you can simply play team 2h
to allow black a move and now the black
will not have rookie three would check
so after after this b3 is coming and now
there is no rookie three checks so after
pawn captures rook captures and rookie
three and now white is only one point
down but it's a double to h1 and this
white should be able to hold this to a
draw but instead rook to be it was
played
we have h4 and now Rock the g8 Annan
said that this is the move that could
have been played better he says that
simply continuing with rook the c8
should be should be alright for white
but in fact rook to g8 is the strongest
move recommended by the engine so island
played correctly so Rob g8 we have king
to h5 and now rook back to f8 attacking
the F pawn rook to f4 defending rogue
back to see it and now comes rope to g4
rock to f8 rock to g3 would check King
h2 and now came to g5 Ruby Jade check we
have King to f4 and now rook to c8
attacking the c4 pawn but this is the
position cousin had in mind he he
doesn't intend to to keep an eye on the
c4 pawn he plays King to e3 rook
captures on c4 and now f4 and now this
is the problem if if this was the
position on the board and Anand didn't
have the these two points then the
position would have easily been a draw
and well a white can still act
we played this out to a draw but it's
very difficult
this is move 60 and here honestly the
rook to a for rook to a four is is not
the greatest move here the only move
White has is actually be four before
what's the idea that after Carlson plays
h3 which is the move of course you have
to play to get rid of the jeep one and
then to push your F pawn this is the
idea G captures on h3 now rook to g5 so
you can start pushing your F pawn rook
the c6 and now this will be a draw the
Arab c6 is the move you have to find
rook the c8 isn't that great rook the c6
is best because now after f3 you have
this check and now King has to go to f2
if you move the King away from the pond
then you will not be able to promote the
pawn wife was simply protect it with the
rook or if Rock here then King will be
able to stop the pawn and the rook will
be cutting the King off so the King has
to go to f2 after king to f2 then comes
c4 root 2 G to check King moves and now
after Ruby 1 check King moves and rook
e1 now you have rook captures on h6
which was which is a whole lot better
than if you had your rope there and now
at some point white will of course have
to give up his rook for this f3 pawn but
with all of these passed pawns white
will hold this to a draw so this was his
only only option here and he played rook
to a4 which everyone criticized after
the game and you know we also have a
nice a nice tweet by Nigel short here
here you have it he defends Anand he
says that it was a it was grossly unfair
of chess base to to upend the question
marks - Anand sixtieth move like it was
a huge blunder or something because
defending this position was incredibly
difficult you know especially in a
practical game over the board
so yeah Nigel short to the rescue
something something you don't see very
often so rook to a4 we have h3 now now
there there are no such plans we have G
captures an h3 and rook capture Sanji in
group to g6 now preparing to pull the F
pawn and it's very interesting how
course and saw that he can give up the
material
to be able to push the h-point and then
create a passer here the F bond and that
Islands own pawns will be will be
stopping Anand from checking our calls
and scheme so a very nice very nice
position where you know white would
actually prefer not having the two
passed pawns on the Queen side but you
know okay
c4 we have f3 and now comes Rock a3
check King to e2 before now that we have
f2 rope to a to check King f3 rook to a3
King to f4 and now rook to e8 preventing
the pawn which rope to a one doesn't
told you all that much simply rook e6
preparing rook e1 and then after roblox
simply king of three now now a rook e1
is coming you you can try to pull the
pawns but here simply rook to c1 will
either pick up the C pawn or if you put
B 7 and then Ruby 1 and there's no way
for you to protect the point anymore so
black is completely winning here
so after King to a 4 we have rook to e8
now rope to g1 and it was in this
position that Vishwanathan Anand
resigned at the game there is nothing
you can do here after after a couple of
checks are given then simply this point
will be promoted and there's nothing you
can do another way Coulson could have
ended this is actually by simply
promoting immediately but to a knight
and then after in each one now comes
Knight here with the threat of Knight f3
and rook to g1 checkmate but you know
it's a World Chess Championship game
there's no reason to the terrorists
doing something like this and overlook
anything but after a couple of checks
Knight f3 is coming and now rock to g1
will be checkmate so white would have to
give up the rock here and then it's all
over
it's a rook against a couple of points a
Badia after rook to g1 Anand resigned
the game and another nice victory in a
row for Carlsen so the first six games
are over first four games were drawn and
then cousin wins two in a row so this is
the first half of the tournament cousin
has a two point lead and now we're gonna
continue with the other games to come in
this
this championship so and you know twelve
games should have been played but if one
player gets six and a half points then
the match is over immediately and there
is no more reason to play out all the
games so yeah I would like to think
about is being taught us unit and Marco
aurélio Anton Giovanni Timothy car and
Jessica Jones for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon
most likely with Game seven of the 2013
World Chess Championship match and so I
don't forget I will put a link in the
description to the press conference
after this game do check it out as its
it's very interesting how a journalists
journalist really starts annoying Anand
and then you know Alan really gets upset
and tells him something very very nasty
but you know do check it out it's it's
very enjoyable you know it's part of
just history so yeah thank you and I
will see you soon